yeah Brunell the founder and CEO of uh
notable and he will be giving us a talk
on that
python with uh
paper mill origami and Vietnam
I think you like it before the question
at the end of the session like yeah so
please hold on to your question to the
question and answer time thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
awesome thank you
um
so I'm gonna cover two parts One's Gonna
Be about
GPT
I'm gonna go for your class because I
really want to give a live demo which is
the fun part
and Philadelphia prepared
a bit of context
about me quickly um our friendship Swiss
I'm here in Seattle
I'll connect your free and my background
is in spiritual engineering and decision
Sciences I've built the train station in
Jeddah in Saudi Arabia if you don't find
me talking about data science I'm gonna
write about time
so that's why I do
also the CEO of notable
um if you don't know about the people
already give it a shot at apple.io
we mostly make it easy to access that
and compute we help people write with
python SQL and your code and we are with
different type of use cases from machine
learning ETL to building dashboards
so are we able to focus the talk on
something that I hope is gonna become
possible and you will see with the demo
and the live video I'm doing
what I call data science on the go my
dream is using kind of a lamp now seeing
how you can not just always like the
other talk you have seen which should be
very high and we have something like
that as well bring
um into the notebook but I will bring
the iPad internal on your mobile on your
device so wherever you are you can just
ask maybe an assistant to do some
prediction for you to do some data
science operation and then you go back
to your computer maybe the next day or
whenever you are back on your tripod
you're on the bus on the park and see
the code that has been generated and
take it from there so it's really kind
of a different approach to that
AI we have a similar package and
Microsoft has been working on one as
well everyone's been working on one so
I'm gonna talk about that a bit and the
second password
which is the most interesting part of
the talk and I'm going to give a live
demo about that
so the first pop I'm gonna go pretty
fast
there's a bunch of repo now plugins
extensions about all of that I got LGBT
the HTTP which was the top history there
there is one for Microsoft as well I
just found out there was a brother
extension now that you can use
ours is called gen AI we release that
analog a couple of weeks ago or months
ago now there is like all of those just
reproducing the experience that you have
been chatting with you within your
account so you have an assist magic and
our focus is also mostly on the
automatic rendering which is the path
that I'm gonna focus on here instead of
just relying everything on you providing
comments because we talked about how
there is a machine to machine
interaction kind of fencing our GPT can
just talk to the notebook automatically
and we felt the error in the trace back
was the best place to start actually the
I think the CTO president of open AI
when they produce GPT
before I don't remember did that exact
example manually on that live stream he
took the trace back in Jupiter put it
back in the chat and it got kind of uh
feedback from that there's a YouTube
live stream and notebook example you can
click
whenever you will have access looks like
so why did we focus on the automatically
focus on errors and exceptions is
because when you write a notebook errors
is very disrupting this repeat very
frustrating it's very difficult to
understand most of the time you always
scroll down to the last line of the
trans back and so there is a lot of
opportunity for
improvements even the the fighting
column improved a lot lately by trying
to provide the insight into the
traceback and the department around it
is really focusing on trying to make
more sense of those errors
and there's a dog below since the last
update around the E who improved
messages so what we did is create custom
exception Anglers
to try to transform that obscure
messages that was describing and try to
have a feedback to chat gbps we context
aware because at context as you all know
is gonna make
um more relevant but what we are talking
about and of course as part of the
integration as we give more and more
context about the runtime about what's
in memory about applying that within the
project everything that you can give to
chat GPT will help it makes more sense
all of that the goal is to streamline
the iteration process
so the benefits like I said improve the
dialogue between the user and system in
action and really embracing the fact
that making errors is great and that's
what I call error Max perfect
so you can see a screenshot here I might
give a demo of that if we have time at
the end after I focus on the second part
but basically this package you can just
load it put your own API key from open
Ai and each time there is an error it
will automatically provide a suggestion
and then it's going to format the
markdown in the code and you're going to
be able to just do whatever you want
with it either ignore it do something
else take it replace your code it should
be module in the process of taking your
next step we don't have buttons we don't
have like a wide Jupiter lab because
it's best to be walking into the classic
in the first place but it's really
something that's automated rather than
you having to call something
so the way it works you can look at the
repo I just want to give you some
context about it
um so it's about registering
um
um basicallypt and the customization
Handler you can see that we incorporate
in the notion of user system and system
trolls on the right and we Define the
system role and also we provide
protection information from the user in
our implementation in notable on top of
the open source package what we did is
really give access to the valuable
explorer that give all the schema of the
data frame which is access to the
dependencies on the project so 3gp knows
about the files that's sitting alongside
the notebooks and that's really helped
provide better better suggestion
so that's implementation detail what I
was talking about uh we provide code
history provide output encoding because
including the output is always very
difficult we are working right now on
really trying to pass better the data
frame to make sure that for the
tokenization we won't go out of memory
so that actually can be faster and also
not bail on us and having to end all the
world like telling them process with
name chain and trying to like build the
real dagger recruits there so we are
trying to make it very simple so there
is no addition the firmware that we have
to use such as an engine which is the ad
set thing jupiteria has been doing
the takeaway is more efficient for
experimentation and interactions
the fact that you have it within the
notebook and it's within your runtime uh
which has access also to the selection
context of your Netbook the limitation
of course is
um that depends on the cooperation of
the model right now it's only supporting
gpt3 we didn't do the work today to be
multi-modal mode to be multimodal models
but if you want to collaborate there is
a genie repo you can look at it you can
compare to all the other side I shared
on the slides we love to contribute to
the other ones as well I really like the
one from gpti by AWS teams so yeah I'm
pretty excited about that section so now
we want to focus on the part 2 which is
the most exciting for us which is
bringing netbooks into activity
so how do we do that
we did that basically by relying on the
experience the experience that we had at
our previous company so I come from
Amazon my city will come from Netflix
where he worked on paper mill that you
might be aware of if you are not type of
slide to explain what it is I think
there was a talk about just before this
one but not serverless notebooks
execution which is pretty relevant about
that we built a library called paper
mill origami that sits on top of it what
does it do
um it's basically how to provide the
next execution so in notable we respect
all the formats of Jupiter respects all
the protocols we just move everything to
the back end in plain English to be able
to enroll real-time collaboration and
real-time things so the origami is here
as an engine to retry to being able to
trigger and understand their tasks that
we are setting from the back end and
being able to do it as less execution
like creating sales editing sales and
taking care of running the kernel
organist which is basically the notable
plugin we built is just a fast API web
app and of course we use the wi because
we did the
the full back-end changes but you know
if Jupiter has implementation with
everything City in the back end will be
produced to tell you one for that
so a quick intro about paper mill I'm
gonna be very fast because we have a
sideline but I think it's important for
you to understand what paper mill is
about
was built at Netflix and it's really
used
by mostly orchestrators as you see on
the right it has been used also the
other do you know about Microsoft so you
put there but I know asset maker because
I worked there that it has been used
internally as well to orchestrate
notebooks it has been used at Google
uh my CTO Matthew CEO who used to work
at Netflix Camp a lot of talks years ago
there's a podcast if you want to learn
more about it but basically paper mills
will be the orchestra for your notebooks
you can Define the the input the output
it's really serving you as a as a way to
not only make it your producible but
also creating snapshots which if you are
if you are using Jupiter without any
other link which is the typical
contributed books paper mill is really
helping with that traceability of
usability as well
here in the ears and example of file we
use peppermint on ways in Daxter it
works with all the other orchestration I
know union union and flight is here it's
exactly the same seller just you
understand how paper mill interacts with
the with the back end of our rgbt
notebooks and with the orchestra here
um Daxter but it's kind of the same
setup to to our friend when I'm going to
show you about LGBT
so um with the partners that you can
Define within your netbooks within your
cell that's gonna trigger another
version
we do the what we call the
materialization of the run the notable
Network becomes an asset in your in your
taxster and that's basically how it
works there is a Long blog post about it
uh we gave a talk at Pai de la New York
last year here I'm just going very very
fast on that because of the the main
content of the talk where it's important
for you to understand our paper million
orchestrian tax with notables
um API and as well with the external
wall which shares Daxter but in our
example it's going to be judging
so strategory without I fighting if you
go to traffic with you and you say
create a notebook
um you know whatever point you want
create me a notebook please it's just
going to tell you white those which is
create a notebook you can run those
commands and then you can open Jupiter
yourself and click on the button
with our plugin what do we bring like I
said with our integration of paper mill
or garden which is our Asus python
library to be able to understand our
backend their tasks we bring less
education so we bring a live kernel to
3050 we bring the notion of Eye of
storage so understand the code and the
output and we bring of course the
dependencies which brings more context
which is you know the default runtime or
the default base images
um the the csvs or the file that's
sitting alongside important
so we have a quick here's a quick video
and then I will jump into like demo and
I think it's very Interactive
the video I'm gonna zoom in
but I'm gonna play faster so let's move
on to the next one basically you see on
the left is using the plugin
you can see from when you open the
description that it's making the request
to notable notebooks which is
um during the file ID and cell ID
and it's gonna kill the cell that you
just created
we actually what we built about
collaboration and notable we pushed back
the change to the project Jupiter so now
there's a there's the same notion of
output ID and and cell ID in the in the
project pattern that we are using
ourselves
so what's important as well GPD can make
mistakes
and we're gonna see that also when when
I give you live demo and for example
here when I was running it using our
plugin
you see that it understands that it
forgot to run the sale that was
previously in the network but the class
context of the network so it knows that
there is a sale which we can sold before
that
and he says okay I'm going to fix this
and I'm gonna rerun to sell a bob that
as the the people installed and and then
we run the entirely
book so it makes me make mistakes but at
the same time as context of the internal
group
here's an example when I'm um asking to
play with field sequel
and uh actually asking also some details
about the shot specification to do some
uh specific conditions for matching on
it
so while we're building that we are
building that because we really want to
think about how you can be maybe on your
phone like I said at the beginning of
the talk thinking about
um using using charity PT or any other
models in the future if we make it work
on different models then any wire that
you have maybe on your phone on those
laptop you don't have access to on that
book you won't have access to Internet
with the Wi-Fi you just have you know
quality or productive whatsoever and you
can just maybe have an interface and say
hey please quick here quick create your
notebook use this file or press API run
the prediction mode and it will
automatically not just give you the
resource but actually generate the
content
[Music]
but the issue is that it's just
ephemeral it doesn't write the code for
you it doesn't save a notebook it
doesn't give you the reproducibility of
what the of what the kernel decided to
do and what the model decided to do
so I have an example this morning I was
driving and yes I didn't do that by
driving maybe
um and you don't know Korean well and
after that we're gonna do live demo
because open AI big issues this morning
and they broke our plugin and then fixed
it
but basically I was on my phone while
not driving
and I said create a book called pie data
demo and I'm gonna move faster because
you that issues this morning
and so look at the book by that they
might have been created successfully you
can access it by clicking here's the
link I will click on it if I wanted a
message in a second using my laptop
and I said average Define
New York city that is USB to explore
modeling approaches and feature
engineering so I did a lot of this thing
for a torque during this week during the
conference you must have seen me maybe
on my computer and it's funny because
the more specific I was
the less useful charging Beauty was at
first I was like I read this model by
myself it's a demo I do a lot when I try
to talk about notable
is your city bike example which is the
common data set sitting on bitcoin
pretty big data set and I did it in our
regression myself which works really
well and I give that demo and it's a
great demo because in 2020 there is the
status model I'm going to show you when
it works well and I I do a pretty pretty
amount of regression I use Canon
calendar feature with our features
and I tried the entire way to tell
certificate do exactly that to put in
your regression and using kind of
features using weather features and it
just didn't work at all and then I
started doing just do machine learning
please and that's why it was the best
app now what was interesting is the more
I I did it you know there's something
happening you see the dot you should not
do that but
um the more I did it each time with the
same Chrome title different results
which was very surprising to me
because you know even if there's some
probabilities and like I give exactly a
simple all the time there is no
additional contact with the context
that's very your snapshot of my project
with a with a file that's there it's the
first cell of The Notebook it can
sometimes do random first and sometimes
do a pretty amount of regression so
allows to show you that we are working
on trying to make it work on mobile as
much as we can and I don't like them
so
let's try that
so on the right side is our UI I'm on
CSV here because yeah we can open csvs
on your tablet view it's not the topic
here for the October so
I don't know maybe I need to refresh
your page we'll see
let's try and say uh create a notebook
it's called
underneath
and then you'll have to reference of
agency
it's not working it's a financial fault
so there's a book here but again let's
open the eyes
normally it will show what you saw in
the demo when I can see the notable
notebook and I can introspect into the
API call and I can up to that so you see
creating the notebook here
foreign
anything
I do something I have an example but
it's it's you can't see it too it's like
a bunch of date counts counties in the
group of tweets year months week they
have the week
what's the most
interesting feature
responsible
go
I almost
immaculated me in that book because
I just did
so again normally we will see the
protein like you have seen in my my
slide deck and I will be able to look at
the
at the API request but right now though
but now you're living outside
we're gonna now just to open the weight
that it's working
instead of being able to see what's
happening so what is that is just just
writing the code right now you're just
writing the code again if you can't see
it because of that
sorry it's writing the code then after
that it's done it's just the next thing
to the notebook and because it didn't
say I'm creating a new notebook I'm sure
it's even now it's gonna appear in this
one for me
should appear in this one let's see
if nothing to create a new one
I mean why are you running it
ah look at that
popped up
so I guess it believes the cell is still
running
I mean
apparently
is it still random
yeah
let's see what it does next
so what we do here we have like UFC in
the maybe in the slide deck the seller
finish running okay it's good
so then that's about the schema
okay
and you perform some present so it's
gonna do
so here again
we don't see a drop down but basically
it's it's picking a set ID creating that
I'm sure python sale
then just dropping the code
so instead of dropping it in the chat
it's just dropping it in the
in that command and then it's gonna just
send them back to
to note the ball here we go
now run that
so what do you do the Instagram for
account box plot and summary metrics
it's more sensitive
nice Adventure it's going to run cell
support
so you know why are you trying to do any
any questions about anyone and we want
to make the second part of this whole
three attack TV creating questions and
feedback as we are working on that
is it something you feel like you're
gonna want to eat on your phone while
you're out in the park like some data
science
no problem
when you have gbt is writing text into
the notebook what user does it show up
as who like who wrote the code
um as
good question we do not try
I I would have to check I think we'll be
doing it as
I don't know it's a good question wait
can we do not track so we have a version
system within your version when we see
the changes made and we go to saving um
we cannot send back
take a look at we couldn't inspect the
consultancy what it's doing and what's
running in the back end but yeah I don't
know
so what is it doing
foreign
not understanding that there is a
cell idea that's there yet or not
so still thinking
um so I have a previous question
um can you also integrate blanching into
this like you dropped in your code and
then asked chat to I don't know to write
a rewrite the code in a simple format um
yeah so there is it has complete notion
of another document so it knows exactly
Michelle is there and uh you might want
to try another example because I'm
always doing here but we it knows
exactly which cell is there the cell ID
the output ID and the academy write cell
content itself so you can say like hey
look at yourself when there is like I
don't know the Instagram and rewrite
that to simplify it or you could say you
know I was doing some example and I will
show you another one
what are you doing
I'll show you another one when I can say
you know get write me another book to
get started with that right man to get
started in this Cube and he's gonna
write it now the same the main issue is
going to be around
the many shoes never around the
the mono of anything you know September
2021 everyone knows that this notion of
additional plugins
so for example
you know the plugins are there to have
just update the model with the the
content in the knowledge that you want
to share it with so in the table the
purpose here is giving it giving it an
eye pattern kernel and somewhere to
write it back to where the other
building store or contact survey it is
giving you access to an API to have some
additional data so you can combine it to
three plugin here I'm sure Lang chain
and others will come up with the same
same kind of system
and if not you can you know ask it to
let's let's do another example for
instance
at a good one which is
uh let me check and the good one which
was about the
the stuff from scratch and say let me
find the name of the API already
foreign
with an API or something like that it's
going to write the entire and look for
you when it's gonna work
yeah so this one let's say can you write
a notebook to
retrieve
the
uh well did I call it already
the position the flights position
in the public
Open Sky
pressed in the iPhone
ah at least it's better here obviously
what's what it's doing
so let's go back to our project which is
by demo
so you just created a notebook here
right
since I think it's more interesting for
you to see
the request here as a response
so here that it's not because you can
stop working the sale so you see the
five ideas that ID
subtitle source
stuff
writing the entire request into one cell
the one issue is as you can see it's a
very smart in terms of I'm sure you
could do a prompt to say you know
segment your own
the call or you're working different
cells but it's usually if it's one code
sales it's gonna write everything into
one good cell in terms of instead of
like
segmented here it does it because my
prompt is pretty generic so it's always
trying to like provide magnet sales for
explanation
but really the insurance value is that
possibility of
building notebooks without having access
to your maybe you know whatever
environment you have at the time you're
not doing that
and generating that content that is
installed you can always go back to
uh I have a full question and do you
think you can also turn this into some
sort of Auto GPD dialogue setup like
using your plugin
I think
I think you'll have to use different
framework to do that because there is no
feedback from here
um maybe you could I think
does and all that stuff is like it's
it's really about reading feedback
through playing short-term memory and we
we are not doing that here it's more
about
you know it's a request and it's a
little feedback about the request and
then we are trying to just have one
action and now if judging is segmenting
it saying you know I have to segment
that into multiple code sales because
that's what I learned from the from the
data I am it's not really I don't call
that an agent at all it's more like we
give it one goal and it's gonna maybe do
multiple steps in that bull if it's what
you're referring to because I see those
in why when you give it one goal and
it's like segmenting into multiple
statements yeah I'm gonna do it I think
it's Asian GPU whatever is doing that
now yeah so ICC 19 in terms of them why
but
maybe I would not call that like an
agent at all I'll just call that you
know we give it we give it one action we
need that's to do two or three courses
to do it you will do that
I don't know why it's not running the
cell
let me run it here
thank you
any other question
for example
do you feel like to laugh but did that
this way I will not change anything
how do you feel about the quality of the
car
yeah
sounds good
thank you
[Applause]